let's just bring you some breaking news
and reports from the russian news agency
interfax in the last few minutes uh say
that the former russian president
mikhail gorbachev has died he was 91
years old he was known for his policy of
glasnost and perestroika opening up the
country to the west he was the eighth
and final leader of the soviet union and
while he wanted to preserve
communism and the history he certainly
believed that reform was necessary
in the soviet union after what happened
at chernobyl he was born to a peasant
family stock in fact um and as i said
the eighth and final leader of the
soviet union the general secretary of
the communist party of the soviet union
from 85 until 1991 uh actually aged 92
apologies um this is the russian news
agency interfax
reporting um he was also the country's
head of state from 1988 until
1991 and as i said he was the man that
began the breakup of the soviet union
believing in reform opening the country
up to the west and of course much of
that one would argue has been undone by
vladimir putin who now wants to who now
wants to uh restore if you like the
might of the soviet union to power and
uh certainly he would blame mikhail
gorbachev for the breakup of these the
15 federal parts of the soviet union
back then so he died we're told uh in
hospital let's just get you the detail
on that more detail coming through um in
fact yes both the tas and ra novosti and
interfax news agencies all citing that
he died at the central clinical hospital
and gorbachev's office said earlier that
he was undergoing treatment at that
hospital so uh all of those russian news
agencies now reporting that this man
that caused those seismic changes to the
soviet union and the former soviet
president mikhail gorbachev has died so
the very latest on that and we'll
certainly get much more reaction as i
said famed for glasnost perestroika at
the end of the eighties
um and uh
yes his apologies his age keeps changing
he's 91 so uh widely considered one of
the most significant figures of the
second half of the 20th century
gorbachev remains the subject as a said
of controversy for those who believed in
the soviet union's continuation
the recipient of a wide range of awards
including the nobel peace prize he was
praised for his pivotal role in ending
the cold war introducing those political
freedoms in the soviet union and
tolerating both the fall of marxist
leninist administrations in eastern and
central europe if you remember this led
to the fall of the
berlin wall uh as well
um and uh and up subsequently led to the
reunification of germany great changes
in eastern and central europe the
expansion fundamentally you would argue
of the european union uh in the decades
to follow and then conversely he's often
derided in russia itself for
accelerating the dissolution of the
soviet republic an event which brought a
decline in russia's global influence and
precipitated an economic collapse and as
i said some might argue that what we're
witnessing in ukraine today is uh
undoing some of mikhail gorbachev's
reforms and vladimir putin's ambitions
to restore the might of the soviet union
as i said which broke up in those 15
republics
pictures there as you can see of ronald
reagan this is all part of the
opening up as i said the great change
that uh brought about the fall of the
soviet union uh those pictures as you
can see the relationship the close
relationship these two men had
and the nobel peace prize winner um you
know you remember those words we heard
in the past of it being ein berliner the
necessity that the
berlin wall should fall down and that
germany was reunified all followed the
changes that this man brought in uh
mikhail gorbachev really quite seismic
in in 20th century global affairs and as
i said the news agencies across russia
now reporting that he has died after
receiving treatment in a central
hospital
and um
many people no doubt will pay tribute to
the work of mikhail gorbachev certainly
in the west if not in russia itself
and as i said derided in many parts
there because the soviet union which had
been one of the two great superpowers
fell apart after the changes that were
begun by mikhail gorbachev perestroika
glasnost opening the country to the west
and allowing
economic change as well
let's just get a little bit about
more about that and his relationship
with margaret thatcher from john craig
john
well back in 1984
uh before he became president of the
soviet union mikhail gorbachev came to
the uk and margaret thatcher famously
described him as a man she could do
business with now in the 1980s um
margaret thatcher was very keen to
improve relations with the soviet union
as it was then and courted uh mikhail
gorbachev uh she saw him as something of
a modernizer uh glasnost perestroika
were the words being used at the time
and
as here in now in
2022 of course
the appalling relations between
uk the rest of europe and russia and war
with president putin in ukraine what a
difference in the 1980s there's mr
gorbachev alongside president reagan in
the 1980s
and uh
he had a very good relationship with
margaret thatcher and later with john
major
i remember a visit that uh pres that
gorbachev made to
the uk including a visit to parliament
in the house of commons um
and john major i remember took him round
the house of commons and i remember
being on the house of commons terrace
when um
john major took gorbachev and introduced
him to dozens of mps back bench mps
labour conservative and it was
fascinating and there were a few a few
quite a few journalists there obviously
watching and observing what was going on
and
he was i don't know whether it's fair to
say that he was possibly the most pro-uk
russian leader of recent times but
certainly in those days in the 80s and
early 90s relations were
so different from what they are now and
uh there's a photo of mr gorbachev with
bran thatcher i'm not sure what year
that is but he did make a number of
visits to here to um the uh the uk
and relations then were very good partly
because
margaret thatcher of course who uh was
of course um uh anxious to bring the
cold war to an end um and one thinks
back you think back to the thatcher
years 1979 to 1990 i mean that was the
period of course when she and other
world leaders like president reagan were
trying to bring the cold war to an end
and of course in the late 80s uh the
berlin wall came down and there was an
amazing breakthrough and it was mr
gorbachev must take a lot of the credit
for that and i suppose you have to give
credit to margaret thatcher and ronald
reagan who as we know were ideological
soul mates great allies in helping bring
about the changes um in russia and the
soviet union as it then was and in
international relations so um
those who were involved at that time
diplomats who worked for margaret
thatcher will no doubt uh will pay a a
warm tribute to his role and uh in in
that in his talks is uh with the
margaret thatcher back in the 1980s and
she obviously
was perhaps should be credited for
spotting his potential before he became
the president courting him back in 1984.
i'm old enough to remember that visit
1984. it was
as i say it was before he became
president and he was seen very much as
the heir apparent and that's why
margaret thatcher was so keen uh to
build up good relations with him and she
certainly did and uh it's uh he uh he's
his role in the ending of the cold war
and a thor in relations
um cannot be underestimated and of
course many people will say how tragic
it is that events in the ukraine and
russia
are so terrible now and that europe is
at war with the leader of what is now uh
the success
successor
to the old soviet union
yeah it's an absolutely fascinating part
of history isn't it 1989 the critical
year uh john most of those marxist
lenders states of central and eastern
europe um you know began their
revolutions if you like um holding
elections resulting in regime change
most countries like poland and hungary
achieve peacefully but if you remember
romania and the ceausescus were
overthrown and executed
and then of course he visited germany in
1989 as well parts of the war began
being taken down a decision apparently
gorbachev praised but really critical
part of european history then the
reunification of germany
and as i said before this all paves the
way for those eastern european states to
be brought into the fold of the european
union and it was ukraine's ambition to
be part of the eu which began
if you like this road with russia which
has seen the anger of vladimir putin
well let's bring in our international
correspondent now alex rossi who's
worked himself um in russia for many
years alex and how will gorbachev be
viewed there and indeed how will that
contrast with how's he seen here in the
west
well i think globally i think you have
to see uh gorbachev mikhail kovachov
he's one of the most significant figures
of the 20th century but within russia he
holds a controversial
uh position particularly as we have seen
the rise of vladimir putin
and the direction with which he has
taken the the country remember putin
himself
has called the craps of the soviet union
the greatest geopolitical uh catastrophe
of the 20th century and the architect of
that as far as many people are concerned
was mikhail
gorbachev you have to i think go back
really to his student days he was uh
very pro
destalization around the khrushchev
period to see really how his
uh political ideas were formed now he
didn't himself this is one of the things
that's misunderstood about him he didn't
himself want to end the soviet union but
what he saw
was a country that was sclerotic
particularly after
the accident at chernobyl where his
officials tried to cover up
the extent of the disaster the centrally
planned
economy of the soviet mass was losing
badly in the face uh of capitalism think
of things like the star wars program
think of the
ruts that the soviet union got itself
into in afghanistan now there are two
key
uh concepts really that are always
associated with mikhail gorbachev that
what one is glasnost uh the russian word
for openness and the other is
perestroitis perestroika restructuring
what he tried to do
was reinvent the soviet union but uh
what actually happened because
and i think most historians would agree
of it with this well because of the
inherent contradictions uh within the
system it kind of all pulled apart and
he was not a strong enough leader to
hold it together now i suppose as a
counter factual
exercise if you if you ask the question
if vladimir putin was in the situation
of mikhail gorbachev would would it have
all held together and historians often
point to what was happening in china at
the time it too was falling behind but
what it got was more authoritarianism
but a capitalist system that didn't
happen as we saw in the soviet union
eventually all of it pulled pulled apart
with revolutions starting uh in 1989 in
eastern european countries and then of
course uh we saw the dissolution of the
soviet union in 1991 but i think he's a
fairly controversial uh figure within um
within russia uh it will be interesting
to see
uh what his his legacy will be written
up there uh over the coming hours
as well sorry
yes and uh alex many russians never
forgiven gorbachev for the turbulence
that his reforms unleashed considering
the subsequent plunge in living
standards um
suggesting that's too high a price to
pay for for their apparent democracy but
also all of this led to such changes in
europe itself i mean you know the german
reunification was pushed through too
swiftly if you like for ronald reagan
and margaret thatcher for some um but
also all those changes that that led to
the growth of the european union and as
i suggested ukraine wishing to become
part of that and here we are now in in
in 2022.
yeah i mean internally within uh russia
the situation if you can go back to the
1990s
uh initially there was this sort of
sense that they may be arriving uh in a
new sort of corridor of history that
would usher in greater freedoms greater
wealth and there was a good deal of
excitement about that but what they
actually ended up with in those early
years was a plunge in living standards
as you were saying
a plunge in life expectancy
and gangster capitalism it was
enormously tough for many people
particularly as the western economists
got involved along with their sort of uh
the the russian politicians that were
involved in what was known as shock
therapy this massive transformation of
the centrally planned economy to a
capitalist system now some people became
very very rich in all of that we saw of
course the rise of the oligarchs but for
most people it was an extraordinarily uh
difficult time now what they found and
this is the key really to understanding
the present that we are living in with
the rise of putin's russia what they had
in vladimir putin was a man who was
going to restore the pride that people
had
in the system on a personal level this
is a man who doesn't really drink is
extremely disciplined um the man he took
over after after all was boris yeltsin
who would stagger around embarrassingly
for many russians drunken
on the international stage and now and
now we see of course uh putin trying to
restore a kind of soviet union 2.0
bringing back what he considers the near
abroad the sort of smaller part of the
russian empire in ukraine now it's
interesting that um
mikhail gorbachev actually made um a
number of comments about that in 2014
really blaming um the west in many ways
for
exacerbating the the tensions that
existed there uh by making things a lot
worse uh we've heard of course that
argument made by vladimir putin over the
years about the expansion of nato
lapping against russia's borders now
that certainly appears to have been
gorbachev's view as well towards the end
of his life